le grand entretien de la matinale avec
Marion lourd notre invité était à la COP
28 il y a quelques jours à peine pour y
parler sécurité alimentaire et
développement des forêts il vient de
présenter son pacte orientation agricole
ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire vos questions
vos interventions chers auditeurs au 01
45 24 7000 au standard dans quelques
minutes ou sur l'application FRANCE
INTER dès maintenant bonjour Marc fen
bonjouronjour et bienvenue beaucoup de
questions à vous poser commençons
d'abord par le bilan de la COP puisqu'on
en a fait le bilan énergétique on en a
fait le bilan en matière de transition
écologique vous y étiez vous pour parler
de la fin dans le monde et de la
possibilité d'assurer la sécurité
alimentaire en limitant le réchauffement
climatique c'est la question qui était
au cœur d'un rapport publié par l'ONU à
Dubaï pour la sécurité alimentaire
735 millions de personnes sont en
situation de famine aujourd'hui à
travers le monde c'est près de 10 % de
la population mondiale c'était déjà un
objectif du Millénaire en 2000 l'ONU
s'était fixé l'objectif d'éradiquer la
famine on est 23 ans après et on en est
toujours là et on y est pas et le le
dérèglement climatique c'est pour ça que
je souhaitais me me rendre à la COP 28
il va poser encore plus cette question
de la famine et de l'ératicité
climatique va produire de l'ératicité de
production et donc de la difficulté à
nourrir tout le monde donc on a besoin
de travailler sur un de la souveraineté
c'est-à-dire de permettre à chacun des
pays de pouvoir retrouver une part de de
de souveraineté alimentaire la
souveraineté je le dis souvent ce n'est
pas le repli sur soi c'est pas
l'autarciie mais c'est la capacité quand
même à produire un minimum de choses sur
son territoire avec des des contraintes
physiques des contraintes climatiques
qui sont évidemment d'une nature
différente selon les climats sur lequels
on se retrouve et donc on a besoin de
coopérer avec ces pays-là on a des
choses à apprendre aussi d'ailleurs sur
la question climatique de la part de ces
pays qui sont sous contraint
stress hydrique stress hydrique je
j'étais au Maroc aussi cette semaine et
on voit bien à quel point on a besoin
d'apprendre la rareté des choses et
comment on essaie de gérer cette rarté
donc on a besoin de coopération et puis
deuxième élément l'agriculture elle peut
participer puisque c'était la COP 28 à
la décarbonation c'estàd qu'une partie
de la solution dans le stockage dans les
sols donc c'est les pratiques
agroécologiques et dans les stockages
par exemple dans les forêts la question
justement fait débat est-ce que vous y
êtes favorable au stockage du CO2 dans
les sols puisque c'est un jet qui divise
encore profondément les technologies
sont compliquées elles nécessitent de
des investissements coûteux et on en
connaît pas encore l'efficacité Marc F
alors je reconnais volontiers je parlais
pas de ce stockage là dans le sol je
parlais du fait de mettre de la matière
organique dans les sols de fait de faire
pousser des plantes qui stockent du
carbone par la photosynthèse ça c'est du
stockage me semble-il plus avéré c'est
un stockage multimillionnaire si je peux
dire puisque c'est l'histoire de la vie
sur terre aussi veux que l'agriculture
et la vie sur Terre le stockage dans les
sols il y a des tas d'interrogation
effectivement un sur le coup deux sur
l'efficacité et trois il y a quelque
chose qui peut interroger c'est sur le
fait que ça permet de dire on continue à
utiliser le pétrole comme on veut
puisqu'on va pouvoir le stocker il y a
un moment ce carbone il faudra bien
qu'il se relâche d'une façon ou d'une
autre donc le mieux c'est quand même
d'être économe en gaz à effet de serre
justement l'agriculture c'est le
deuxième secteur émetteur de de gaz à
effet de serre chez nous qu'est-ce qu'on
fait concrètement pour essayer de
limiter ça alors d'abord premier élément
alors ça c'est la biologie qui parle
l'agriculture par nature la
photosynthèse ça produit du gaz à effet
de ser donc on on ne sera jamais à zéro
en agriculture sinon on ne produira rien
euh deuxième élément enfin il y a des
types d'agriculture qui sont oui je je
je vais répondre à la question 2ème
élément maî que d'autres on a on a une
capacité par exemple une partie des gaz
les deux grands pôles du gaz à effet de
ser agriculture c'est les les les
engrais le deuxième c'est l'élevage sous
le sous forme de méthane sur l'élevage
on sait que la trajectoire simplement de
de changement d'alimentation de
complément alimentaire elle permet
parfois de réduire simplement de 20 à 30
% le l'alimentation le l'émission de gaz
donc on ne réduit pas le cheptel comme
ça a pu être préconisé je vois pas
pourquoi je réduirai le cheptel dans un
pays qui n'est pas capable de nourrir sa
propre population avec son propre chtel
je veux dire commençons par essayer
d'atteindre des objectifs de réduction
qui soient liés à
l'alimentation plutôt que de dire on
réduit le chtel parce qu'on réduira le
Che chez nous et on aura de la viande
qui viendra d'ailleurs avec des gaz à
effet de ser qui seront plus puissamment
et réduire notre consommation de viande
rouge c'est ça que vous dites NON je je
dis c'est pas ça que je dis je vous dis
l'idée de dire simplement pour la
décroissance du cheptel je résous mon
problème c'est une erreur parce que
tendantiellement il y a une réduction de
la consommation de viande il faut
l'assumer comme telle et la
diversification vous avez l'air de la
regretter non non je la regrette pas
c'est un fait enfin je je on peut pas
être dans le regret quand on est dans
les pratiques alimentaires et la façon
dont les gens se nourrissent et c'est
bien qu'il y ait de la diversité dans
dans notre alimentation y compris avec
des végétaux mais deuxième élément la la
question de l'alimentation du bétail
elle permet de résoudre une partie des
choses et puis deuxième chose qu'on faut
dire si j'ai pas de de de bétail si j'ai
pas d'animaux euh j'ai pas de haie j'ai
pas de prairie
j'ai pas de stockage de carbone dans les
prairies parce que les les prairies l et
elle n'existent que parce qu'il y a de
l'élevage sinon ça serait ça
n'existerait pas il peut pas y avoir du
des a entre les champs et qui les
entretient et à quoi servent-elles s'il
y a pas
d'activité elle peut
servir la à séparer des parcelles oui ça
c'est dans les temps ancestraux mais on
a besoin les parcelles agricoles on rêve
tous de paysage de bocage en
l'occurrence l'agriculture
ind mais c'est pas l'agriculture
industrielle c'est pas l'agriculture
industrielle pardon parce que le terme
industriel une seconde le TER industriel
il est il est impropre c'est quoi
l'agriculture industrielle c'est d'avoir
100 vaches la moyenne des élevages
français c'est 70 à 80 vaches c'est ça
ce que vous appelez aussi les
exploitations mais lesqu desquel
parle-t-on il y a pas d'agric
d'exploitation avec 1000 vaches ça
n'existe pas en France donc
l'agriculture industrielle allez la
chercher au Brésil allez la chercher
parfois en Ukraine mais n'allez pas la
chercher dans un pays où il n'y a pas
d'agriculture industrielle je le je le
dis et je le prétends par alors c'est
paradoxal et j'imagine que ça fera
réagir de nombreux auditeurs dire que la
France n'a pas de de de de d'agriculture
industrielle sur son sol euh c'est
contreintuitif pour le moins mais on va
revenir au plan que vous avez présenté
hier Marc feno un plan important c'était
en 1947 et vous connaissez la référence
Paris et le désert français cétait un
livre d'un géographe Jean-François
gravier qui déjà en 1947 appelait à
repeupler les campagnes et on pouvait
pas ne pas y penser en vous écoutant
hier annoncer ces faits ces chiffres qui
sont très durs d'ici 10 ans un/ers des
agriculteurs seront partis à la retraite
le nombre de fermes s'effondre d'année
en année en France 100000 de moins entre
2010 et 2020 hier vous avez donc
présenté ce ce pacte 36 mesur pour
éviter cette
désertification l'essentiel renouer le
lien entre l'agriculture et la société
qu'est-ce qui alors il y a il y a
plusieurs facteurs me semble le levier
le plus efficace d'abord alors non
premier élément effectivement renouer le
lien entre l'agriculture et la société
parce que si on passe son temps à
dénigrer l'agriculture et à dire qu'au
fond elle n'a que des fonctions
négatives alors que c'est exactement le
contraire on attirera aucun aucun jeune
ou moins jeune d'ailleurs parce qu'il y
a des gens qui viennent pas forcément du
milieu agricole et qui viennent
s'installer en agriculture donc on a
besoin de renouer un lien c'est comment
fonctionne une exploitation agricole
qu'est-ce que c'est que le cycle du
vivant le cycle de la vie et de la mort
parce que si on narrive pas à renouer ce
lien là on a un problème deième élément
on a besoin de travailler sur la
formation d'améliorer la formation
notamment sur la transition comment on
fait sorte que des jeunes qui se forment
soient mieux à même de faire face à ce
que va être le dérèglement climatique
produire sous 2 degrés de plus ça va
être une énorme contrainte même en
France et si c'est quatre ça va être une
contrainte encore plus forte troisème
élément c'est ce qu'on travaille sur les
la question d'avoir un un outil de
diagnostique sur les exploitations qui
permet de ce que le président de la
République avait appelé le stress test
climatique c'est-à-dire de regarder
comment mon exploitation résiste dans
les 10 ou 20 années donc se mettre en
pour les banques et puis dernier élément
pardon c'est la question de l'accès au
fonciers et l'action la question de
l'accès aux capitaux c'est un des freins
pour les jeunes c'estàd vous arrivez il
y a beaucoup de dérèglements climatiqu
géopolitique économique vous allez voir
votre banquier vous dites je n'ai aucune
réponse pour 20 ans et il faut me prêter
500000 300000 1 million d'euros et donc
l'idée c'est de garantir des des crédits
avec la garantie de l'État et puis de de
pouvoir porter pour un temps plus ou
moins long le foncier pour le jeune qui
s'installe pour dire bah dans cette
période là quel il y a un tiers qui
porte le foncier pour toi pour faire en
sorte que ça soit pas une charge trop
lourde parce que l'accès au fonciers on
sait que c'est un élément discriminant
pour un certain nombre de gens d'autant
je pardon je le je le signale que plus
de la moitié des gens qui s'installent
aujourd'hui ne sont pas issus du milieu
agricole c'est une grande chance moi je
crois pour l'agriculture mais il faut il
faut répondre à ce cette sociologie
particulière alors il y a l'accès au
foncier il y a le lien vous le disiez
avec la terre il y a aussi une question
d'argent quand on sait qu' un exploitant
agricole gagne 1031 € par mois en
moyenne est-ce qu'on peut vraiment
parler de l'attractivité de cette
profession sans traiter ce problème là
oui alors ça c'est des des éléments qui
ont été traités en partie al il faut
continuer le travail au travers des lois
dites égalim qui visent à construire le
prix par la valeur de la matière
première par les coûts de production le
travail continue à faire et puis il faut
qu'on ait quelque chose collectivement
en tête c'est que l'agriculture elle a
un coût et donc si elle a un cout elle
doit avoir un prix nous avons
l'agriculture la plus performante
économiquement mais aussi la plus
performante d'un point de vue
environnemental mais les contraintes
qu'on peut accepter en terme
environnemental de qui pèse sur
l'agriculture française faut qu'on les
retrouve dans les prix donc on peut pas
avoir des opérateurs de grande
distribution qui passent leur temps qui
passent leur temps à critiquer au fond
en disant c'est trop cher c'est trop
cher c'est trop cher et dans le même
temps dire on veut une agriculture qui
porte un certain nombre d'exigence sinon
là il y a un paradoxe bah le paradoxe
c'est celui qui traverse chaque citoyen
chaque consommateur marû c'est vrai mais
la représentation qu'on a donné à la la
valeur alimentaire elle est dégradée
depuis 60 ans on on donne plus de valeur
aux objets technologiques que j'ai à
côté de moi tout le monde se f pour qui
n pas l'image tous ceux qui c'était pour
pas faire de pub tous ceux qui euh tous
ceux qui nous écoutent savent à peu près
l'inflation du prix de dépat et personne
ne sait l'inflation de ce cet objet
justement Marc PHENO le prix on on
prévoit l'INC prévoir ralentissement de
l'inflation 2,56 % sur un an en juin
prochain mais c'est la fin du trimestre
anti-inflation qui avait été mis en
place qui avait été appelé par le
gouvernement dans dans les grandes
surfaces il y avait 1600 produits qui
faisaient l'objet d'e d'une remise de 2
et demi à 3 % par les industriels de
l'agroalimentaire est-ce que il faut
craindre nous clients aussi nous
consommateurs de voir les prix bondir
dans dans les rayons avec la la fin de
ce trimestre non les les prix ne vont
pas bondir faut pas se je crois pas
qu'il faille se faire la grande peur de
l'inflation alors après on reviendra pas
au niveau d'avant 2021 les salaires ont
augmenté l'énergie reste haute il y a un
certain nombre de produits je pense au
sucre par exemple qui sont encore très
élevés du fait de d'une production qui
rare le dérèglement climatique qui
produit tout ça et donc ne nous faisons
pas peur avec une très grande hausse de
l'inflation mais nous nous faisons pas
non plus de rêve avec une pas question
d'avoir peur il question d'encaisser le
choc parce que V cè un grand soin c'est
pas la question si il y a un peu un côté
on va avoir un énorme soin
inflationniste non ce pic là est passé
mais parce que votre collègue Olivier
Grégoire a dit il y a les prix qui vont
baisser sur certains produit prochain
vous parlez avec les industriels ils
vous disent ça il y a des prix qui V
baiss il y a quelques secteurs dans
lequel les prix vont baisser alors après
la matière première agricole non mais la
matière première agricole elle n'est pas
déterminante dans le prix final d'un
produit sur un prix de pâte le le prix
du blé é quand même assez marginal
lui-même par rapport à ce que sont les
emballages
les oui on va filer au standard
retrouver Jean
bonjour Jean-Pierre bonjour et bienvenue
dans la matinale d'Inter vous nous
appelez de M et vous avez une question
pour le ministre de l'Agriculture Marc
fen qui est avec nous ce matin oui dans
la dans la région où j'habite allez on
va faire une petite moyenne un jeune qui
veut s'installer dans une agriculture
telle qu'elle existe aujourd'hui il va
devoir mobiliser à peu près 1 million
d'euros 1 million d'euros pour acheter
les terres pour pour pour Lesch B mais
surtout pour acheter du bâtiment du
chtel du
matériel euh alors si on réfléchissait
de la même manière dans l'industrie il y
aurait très peu de d'entreprises
puisque en fait on n pas séparé dans
l'agriculture le travail du capital
nécessaire bah c'est un constat qu'on
peut faire et auquel va vous répondre
Marc fen vous n'avez pas donné de
chiffres d'ailleurs hier Marc fen quand
vous avez présenté votre pacte
d'orientation agricole en tout cas vous
n'avez pas fixé le coût de d'installer
150000 agriculteurs d'ici 10 ans comme
l'avait promis le président de la
République devant le syndicat des jeunes
agriculteurs j'ai dit ce que serait les
chiffres les moyens qu'on qu'on y
consacrait puisque par exemple on va y
revenir les prêt garantis par l'État
pour les pour ceux qui portent le
capital c'est 2 milliards les fonds de
garantie pour le foncier c'est 400
millions c'est quand même il me semble
que c'est des chiffres de ce point de
vue-là la transition c'est 1 milliard
d'euros par an pour les 3 années qu'on a
devant nous au moins donc on a quand
même mis quelqu quel chiff sur la table
et c'est la garantie d'un prêt ça n'est
pas la même chose que l'aide à
l'installation et à l'investissement
comme vient de le présenter Jean Pierre
quand on veut non seulement acheter la
terre mais les machines les bâtiments ça
un coou mais il y il y a par ailleurs
l'aide à l'installation qui existe dans
la pack et qui est un outil mais le
frein principal c'est l'accès au crédit
dans cette affaire là et et ce que dit
Jean-Pierre notre auditeur a raison
c'est le coût d'un million d'euros dans
ce donc d'un million d'euros c'est il
faut c'est lourd à porter donc il faut
garantir le prêt il faut les aides qui
sont celles de la dotation jeune
agriculteur et trois il faut le mettre
dans un système qui économiquement va
être viable et donc qui résiste au défis
climatiques alors pour redonner envie de
faire vivre la campagne et de faire ce
métier magnifique d'agriculteur il y a
de très nombreuses questions sur
l'application FRANCE INTER Marc fenau
qui concerne le salaire les agriculteurs
ne vivent pas ou beaucoup d'entre eux
n'arrivent pas à vivre de leur travail
comment répondre à cette angoisse c'est
à ce bon ce scandale en fait qui dure
depuis maintenant des des décennies
alors d'abord c'est la malheureusement
la vie de l'agriculture c'est des prix
qui sont parfois très élevés des prix
qui sont très bas parce que c'est un je
rappelle que c'est la seule activité où
vous faites rentrer entre guillemets des
facteurs de production vous semmer des
graines vous mettez des facteurs de
l'eau et cetera et au bout vous savez
pas ce que vous allez produire quand
vous faites des automobiles ça marche
pas comme ça quand vous faites des
ordinateurs vous mettez des facteurs
vous savez qu'à la fin vous aurez 10 ou
100 ordinateur et donc il y a beaucoup
d'instabilité déjà par le métier parce
que c'est le ciel qui du ciel que la
production deuxième élément je le répète
ce qu'on a fait au travers des Galim est
un élément très important c'est de
construire les prises sur le lait par
exemple on essaie d'améliorer les choses
les la la rémunération sur le lait s'est
amélioré ces dernières années grâce à
egalim sur un certain nombre d'autres
productions il faut qu'on qu'on continue
à travailler pour faire en sorte que
nous citoyens que par la commande
publique par exemple j'ai été maire et
président de communauté de commune la
commande publique scolaire de décider
que nous avons des produits français
plutôt et des produits et des circuits
courts ou des produit sous la belle bio
c'est à nous aussi de dans la commande
publique de faire en sorte qu'on
privilégie l'agriculture française à une
rémunération qui soit juste bonjour Mona
et bienvenue vous nous appelez de Rennes
et vous êtes indigné faites part de
votre indignation à Marc FO oui bonjour
à tous et à toutes euh voilà pour deux
choses très rapidement la grave question
du glyphosate et deuxièmement la
question un petit peu plus complexe euh
des produits bio euh quand on achète un
produit bio on paye des taxes dans ces
taxes enfin comme les autres hein dans
ces taxes sont comprises une taxe pour
dépollution des terres l'agriculture
biologique ne ne pollue pas je trouve ça
gros de payer cette taxe et en plus
d'entendre les les comment les
agriculteurs
conventionnel dire W les produits bio
sont horriblement chers merci moname
pour une petite chose votre intervention
oui je présente mes excuses aux
consommateurs qui consomment des
produits conventionnels qui n'ont pas
les moyens de se payer les produits bio
voilà merci infiniment Mona vous nous
appelu Dorine Marc F bah c'est de sujets
complexe sur le glyphosate la décision
qui a été prise et vous savez qu'elle a
été la position de la France Ctait dire
on a besoin encore dans un certain
nombre de cas d'usage du glyphosate en
revanche partout on peut réduire on le
fait et c'est ce qu'on fait en France on
a réduit 30 % la consommation de
glyphosate comme quoi il y a une
trajectoire qui est possible
mais ça a été fondé sur l'fsa et l'ansin
c'est c'est sur cette base là qu' a été
fondé la décision la décision européenne
et la façon don la France la bord
deuxème élément non non mais je le redis
quand même parce que c'était la question
deuxième sujet c'est un sujet complexe
sur le bio il y a un sujet de de de
difficulté pour un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens d'y accéder il y a un sujet
d'image qui sur lequel on va travailler
je mets près de 10 millions d'euros
supplémentaires sur la communication sur
le bio le bio c'est pas égal cher de la
grande distribution ne peut pas avoir
des marches qui sont plus importantes
sur le bio que sur le conventionnel
parce que ça veut dire que c'est en fait
on considère que ceux qui achè bio
auraient par nature les moyens plus que
les autres et donc on doit inciter à
travailler là-dessus et puis trois il
faut redire que le bio c'est aussi du
local la crise covid a fait qu'on a été
beaucoup vers les circuits courts bio ou
non bio mais le bio de ce point de vue-
là c'est un peu effacé la baisse de la
consommation bio elle date de l'après
covid et donc on a besoin de travailler
sur la communication sur ce registre une
question vous étiez en Ukraine il y a 10
jours est-ce que vous êtes favorable à
l'entrée de l'Ukraine dans l'Union
européenne c'est la procédure de
adhésion qui a été ouverte cette semaine
et qui pose de nombreuses questions
notamment sur le plan agricole puisque
l'Ukraine est un concurrent potentiel de
la France notamment dans la production
céréalière ça n'est pas parce que c'est
un concurrent potentiel qu'il faut pas
bien sûr que ça peut être un concurrent
potentiel les Espagnols étaient des
concurrents
potentiels il me semble que le processus
d'adhésion oui on doit rentrer dans un
processus de dialogue et d'adhésion
c'est pas pour tout de suite il faut que
ce qu'on appelle l'intégration de
l'acquis communautaire on peut pas faire
rentrer un pays qui n'aurait pas les
mêmes R règles en particulier sur la
question agricole qui sont celles qui
sont les nôtres je disais à mes
collègues Ukrainiens je leur disais il y
a il y a deux sujets un il faut que vous
pensiez que vous ne vous ne viendriez
pas dans cet espace pour devenir des
concurrents des agriculteurs français ou
européens vous devez venir dans cet
espace comme des acteurs économiques
mondiaux et venir faire de la
compétition de la concurrence avec le
Brésil avec les États-Unis avec les
Russes pour faire ça peut être un atout
formidable pour être une puissance
agricole réelle à l'extérieur de nos
frontières parce que le sujet c'est de
savoir qui nous nourrit et qui on
nourrit à l'extérieur de nos qui nourrit
à l'extérieur de nos frontières et je
préfère que ce soit les Ukrainiens
intégrés dans l'Union européenne que des
Russes qui sont désormais nos
adversaires voyez ce que veux dire la
question de la sécurité alimentaire elle
peut se traiter comme ça en revanche ça
peut pas être une entrée qui
contribuerait à venir faire de la
concurrence sur le sur le sol européen à
27 parce que là on aurait un problème
évidemment important Marc fen des
addictologues ont écrit à votre collègue
à la santé Aurélien Rousseau pour lui
demander de soutenir le Dra Januarie le
défi de janvier une initiative qui vise
à à cesser la cons
pendant le mois janvier c'est ça CER la
consommation d'alcool pendant tout un
mois ce serait la la preuve d'une
politique cohérente et résolue contre
l'alcoolisme c'est ce que disent ces
médecins vous seriez prêt vous à appeler
à ce Dra et jar non je suis comme mon
collègue Rousseau je trouve on protège
quand
même mais c'est bizarre comme on dit à
chaque fois quand on est comme ça on dit
on est dans le lobby on a réduit de 70 %
la consommation d'alcool depuis 50 ans
non mais on a réduit cette année on la
consommation d'alcool en France elle est
réduite de 7 à 10 % ça il me semble
queon n pas de le à recevoir de qui que
ce soit sur une trajectoire après on
peut a c'est pas une leçon c'est un test
pour que chacun puisse évaluer sa
consommation faut je pense que les gens
ont un peu assez qu'on vient de leur
dire comment se nourrir comment boire
comment se déplacer parce qu'il y a
quelque chose de de d'une manière de
vivre qu'il faut aussi respecter et je
préfère qu'on soit plutôt sur quelque
chose qui soit de l'incitation
sympathique tout en reconnaissant la
valeur de nos terroirs et en particulier
nos terroirs viticole plutôt que d'être
dans cette chose où un mois il faut pas
faut pas faut pas faut pas boire un mois
il faut pas faire ceci vous allez le
faire vous à titre personnel non je vais
pas le faire parce que je je mais
j'essaie de de faire comme tout le monde
c'est-à-dire de et je me l'applique
assez régulièrement de de consommer avec
modération la mesure et la modération
plutôt que l'interdiction la mesure et
la modération plutôt que la
l'injonction permanente sur le dos des
gens disant en décembre vous avez le
droit bonne fête de Noël bonne fête de
fin d'année et en janvier ça y est on
devient on rentre dans le coercitif et
je répète notre politique de santé
publique en France sur la question de
l'alcool elle a réussi depuis 60 ans
mais on a aussi derrière c'est des gens
qui essaient de faire de faire des
produits qui sont reconnus au travers le
monde et je parle je pense au
viticulteurs bientôt la fin du grand
entretien deux questions d'auditeur la
première elle est formulée de manière
très simple Marc fen y a-t-il des AGR
terroristes en France on a vu la semaine
dernière des images dégradation de bien
d'attaque des forces de l'ordre par des
membres de la FNSEA pourquoi est-ce que
vous condamnez les violences lorsqu'ell
viennent écologiste mais pas celle des
syndicat d' je réponds à la question en
disant que je réponds je jamais vous me
trouverez sur un autre chemin que celui
de dire que la violence n'est pas un
mode d'expression verbal ou physique et
donc je n'accepte pas la violence d'où
qu'elle vienne et je me tiens à cette
ligne strictement dans ce registre
deuxième question et là pour le coup
elles sont nombreuses elles concernent
les a dont nous parlions tout à l'heure
et c'est vrai qu'on peut penser au
paysage normand on peut penser au
magnifique bocage du Bourbonnais par
exemple j'aimerais rappeler au ministre
que les a sont des écosystèmes c'est
vrai dit Guillaume Eveline vous dit que
vous a fait bondir quand vous osez dire
on n pas besoin de haie si on a pas
d'élevage on peut peut-être raser nos
forêts aussi non j'ai pas dit ça j'ai
dit que quand vous regardez etessay on
de pass se caricaturer euh quand vous
regardez les les paysages qui reste avec
DESS c'est les paysages où il y a de
l'élevage voilà historiquement par
ailleurs je suis très très à l'aise de
vous dire ce matin que c'est moi qui
porte impact sur la haie 100 millions
d'euros chaque année pour planter 50000
km linéaires de haie y compris vous avez
raison dans des terres qui ne sont pas
des terres d'élevage c'est mais c'est
plus compliqué dans des terres sans
élevage qui a moins cette culture de
laaie lae est le produit plutôt de
l'élevage que le produit d'autre chose
mais oui on a besoin de ha alors là pour
le coup vous prêchez unconvaincu puisque
je suis en train de faire un plan qui va
permettre de redévelopper la ce qui
s'était pas fait depuis 50 ans en un
seul mot Marc fen parce que c'est la fin
une commission mixte paritaire lundi sur
la loi immigration le président des LR
du des sénateurs LR dit que il veut
revenir au texte du Sénat et qu'il n'y
aura pas d'accord sans cela est-ce que
vous vous êtes prê à cela en tant que
membre de la majoritéin moi j'ai été
misist des relation avec le Parlement je
connais bien le président DLR du Sénat
la commission mixte paritaire c'est pas
non c'est pas le texte du Sénat ou rien
d'autre sinon c'est pas une elle est pas
paritaire elle est pas mixte lisez ce
que dit Monsieur rotillo on va laisser
faire vous savez la commissionitaire
inventée par le général de Gaulle et
Michel Debray elle est formidable parce
qu'elle se fait sans le gouvernement et
sans personne et oui c'est ce que je
dire à H cl et parfois que le débat se
fasse à H en sortant des postures je
trouve que c'est formidable et c'est
d'ailleurs 70 % des texes qui sont votés
aujourd'hui en France sont votés dans le
cas d'une commission mixte paritaire
faisons confiance aux députés et
sénateurs essayer de trouver un
compromis et vive la transparence malgré
tout mais ça nempêche pas la je
plaisante c'était juste pour clur
l'entretien à suivre Marc fen merci
d'avoir été l'invité d'Inter ce matin à
suivre la revue de presse